joining me now is the government
minister nadim zahari mr zahawi always a
pleasure thank you for joining us on the
program this morning um i know that
you're not going to tell me what the
details are of the plan and you'll say
i'll have to wait to hear what the prime
minister has to say
i can ask you though will it fix the
problem
well i think um successive governments
have um attempted to come forward with
plans and have never quite delivered i
think this prime minister
is determined um to actually
fix the broken social care system now
you can't address the social care system
in isolation because you need to make
sure that integration between
health and social care is completed so
you have to also make sure that the nhs
has the funding it needs to be able to
fix the the sort of the shorter term
difficulty of the pandemic which is why
last night we announced an additional
5.4 billion for this six months on top
of the 6.6 billion for the previous six
months of additional spending uh to
allow the nhs to make a real dent into
that uh backlog the five million that
john craig does describe
in uh the backlog and of course we
estimate about seven million people
haven't come forward and i would urge
them to also come forward uh for
uh their operations it's really
important you know we we put one billion
into uh dealing with the backlog in the
last six months
of elective surgery we've doubled that
two billion on the announcement
yesterday so you've got to do both
things you've got to make sure the nhs
has the funding it needs to deal with
the cost of covid and of course enhanced
hospital discharged that's uh getting an
additional just under 500 million
and of course what the prime minister
will announce to parliament and i think
it's right that he does that in
parliament and then there's a press
conference with him and the chancellor
and the secretary of state for health up
later on today to give the details on
how
the social care system uh that so does
require reform one in seven people k pay
over a hundred thousand pounds for their
social care if you have assets of more
than twenty three thousand three hundred
fifty pounds um then your
your social care costs can be absolutely
um
back-breaking so it has to be dealt with
and i think this prime minister will not
shirk
that responsibility and he will set out
his plans today
and in answer to my question
your question around social care how are
we going to whether the question was
will it fix the problem it was a very
straightforward question well i think
look
as i said i think you have to at least
have a really good go and make sure you
fix the problem the social guest is
still not necessarily then
well
it would be presumptuous and i think
completely arrogant to say of course uh
katie will fix the problem
he had a ready-made deal ready to go two
years ago on the steps of dining street
well no
right so there's two different things
it's really important you're the
the right thing to do is to deliver the
reform of social care and the investment
into social care
you've got to make sure then that is
operationalized as we did with the
vaccination program you know
when i came on your programmer when i
took on this role
let's deal with vaccination later on in
the in the conversation let's deal with
whether or not this is going to fix the
problem that labour says it's not they
say it's only going to benefit three to
five percent of people who need it
well i i think actually when you see the
details of what the process will set out
you'll see that this is a primary
serious about fixing the problem i'm
just being respectful and cautious in
that you know and not being arrogant to
say of course yeah everything will be
fixed in five minutes it won't both in
terms of the backlog we'll tackle it we
want to reduce it but it will increase
before it gets better but we're putting
the resources the money that we
announced yesterday the additional 5.4
billion taking the total by the way for
this year alone of additional support to
the nhs to 34 billion pounds
will go some way to addressing the
backlog in the same way i'm not going to
be arrogant
the amount of money twice you've talked
about the amount of money that's going
to the nhs 5.4 billion which was
announced yesterday the health
foundation says to drop in the bucket
and the nhs needs at least 17 billion
pounds to sort out that backlog
well the 5.4 billion is for this six
months there was 6.6 billion in the
previous uh six months
so more forthcoming if necessary that
well as as i say it's really important
that we we deal with both the nhs
getting the funding it needs and yeah my
specific question is whether there'll be
more money forthcoming for the nhs if
necessary if necessary of course we will
continue to look at what the nhs is
because you've got to fix both you you
can't fix social care without having an
nhs that is actually fit for purpose of
course of course i get that and you know
you're making a pledge today on to my
viewers on the program
national insurance you said as a party
in the manifesto would not increase and
yet it looks as though that's what
you're going to do are you completely
comfortable with that
well let's wait and see what the details
uh that we set out by the prime minister
a money tree you're going to have to get
it from somewhere you said that you're
not going to put up national insurance
as part of the manifesto would you be
comfortable if the prime minister
decided that was the only way to pay for
this social care
well i don't want to preempt the prime
minister or speculate i'm just saying if
that's what happened would you be
comfortable with breaking a manifesto
promise but let's wait and see what the
premise has set out the important thing
is to remember feel about breaking a
manifesto promise though
well look i i want to meet every single
manifesto promise that we make that's
the right thing to do
um we have gone through an unprecedented
shock to the economy because of the
global pandemic and we've had to deal
with it and make some really really
tough decisions but i don't want to
preempt uh what the prime minister will
announce or what the chancellor uh will
say in the press conference later on
today very happy to come back on your
show and discuss how we're going to pay
for it the important thing to remember
is that this prime minister will set out
the plan that i think will finally after
successive governments attempting to do
this and failing this prime minister
will actually deal with this and deliver
the funding that will uh fix the the
broken social care system that many many
people even if that means breaking
manifesto promises what about the triple
lock for pensions um that was another
manifesto promise i believe that that
would stay in place are you going to
break that promise too
well first of all
no one is in the business of of wanting
to break any promises there's been
if you look at uh the triple lock that's
been in place and it's been in the
manifesto
the chancellor will set out any spending
plans it would be absolutely uh
premature and i think wrong for the
minister for vaccine deployment to be
setting out the government today
minister you're not here as the vaccine
minister you're representing the
government today i'm putting it to you
on behalf of my viewers that many of
them voted for your party because you
made those manifesto promises i'm asking
you are you comfortable i'm not asking
you what the prime minister's gonna say
i'm gonna i'm asking you are you
comfortable with breaking two manifesto
promises potentially i'm not comfortable
breaking any manifesto promises what i'm
saying to you k is that whatever we do
in terms of the finances of this country
and getting the country back on its feet
as the chancellor has done 407 billion
has gone into that safety net to protect
the economy
eight billion into welfare the
chancellor will set out our spending
plans and we'll explain how we're paying
for the social care reforms that we'll
introduce which will finally i hope
begin that that's a road to dealing with
the fish care problems that we have
faced for many many uh years not decades
got it uh talk to me about an area that
you're much more comfortable with and
that is
vaccines the eye newspaper reporting
this morning that the government is
planning an october fire break
uh if
hospital admissions um stay high is that
something that you would endorse
so
the vaccines have actually allowed us to
reach a an equilibrium with the uh virus
in the sense that they have prevented
over 100 000 deaths um many many
millions of infections and of course
hospitalization as well uh the upward
pressure on infections is obviously
we've reopened uh uh the economy to uh
you know
pretty much uh as close to normal as you
can get
but but obviously schools my question is
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm i'm absolutely
gonna answer your questions
a finite amount of time you're gonna be
here all day at this rate no hold on a
second so so the the
booster program that we've had the
interim advice from the jcvi on is my
absolute priority that will protect the
most vulnerable to serious infection
that will actually help us to transition
this virus from pandemic to endemic
status the important thing is we get
that right because i think if we do that
well we can continue on this sort of
one-way road towards sustaining the
opening of the economy and by next year
hopefully transitioning this virus from
pandemic to endemic and dealing with it
on an annual basis the thing to do is to
remain cultured let me try this one then
let me try this one let me try this one
suggestions that school half term could
be extended from one to two weeks
because those pesky little biters are
the one that keeps spreading this virus
is that a good idea
so i think the the the right thing is
that we open schools we've opened them
well
with the really comprehensive testing
program and we want to make sure they
stay open and the way you do that is by
protecting the most vulnerable which is
why my focus is on the booster program i
don't want to
adjust the half term or go back to any
form of lockdowns because the
that's the worst thing i can do we can
do to the economy and to people's
livelihoods the way to deal with it i'm
not ruling it out um let me ask you
about the migrants crossing the channel
yesterday we were contacted by the home
office last night telling us that it
wasn't a thousand migrants crossing the
channel so they obviously know how many
it was can you tell us this morning
no what i can tell you though is that
well we are working
with the french authorities they've uh
increased the number of patrols and of
course uh they're doubling the number of
police and enhancing the technology but
in the long term it is the uh
nationality and borders bill
that i think will make a real difference
which again this government is the
government not to shirk this
responsibility it's a tough challenge
you you know it's a tough challenge but
we are dealing with it and that
nationality and borders bill absolutely
lays the foundations for dealing with
this issue uh in the longer term in a
sustainable way but we're working with
the french authorities to make sure that
that uh uh that shorter term uh fixes
are also enhanced as much as we can do
we know what nationalities these people
are
very varying nationalities as you know
from many many uh uh countries i just
wonder if only if there might be
afghanis and whether we would treat them
differently
well as you know the prime minister and
the uh foreign sector gave a
comprehensive statement uh two
statements to to parliament on the work
that we're doing to uh
continue to enhance what was an
incredible evacuation program of fifteen
thousand people in uh about a fortnight
which is uh
a testament we paid the french
authorities 54 million pounds to deal
with the situation um on to try and stop
migrants crossing the channel it was a
record number yesterday you can't give
me the number
some suggesting a thousand you're saying
as a government it's less than that but
you can't tell me how many as i said we
paid the french 54 million to manage the
situation um and this was a record
number are we getting value for money
well i think the the the work that the
french authorities are uh doing is
incredibly important i think it's right
to continue to enhance that and the
conversations we've had
with them
is
to to really sort of
hold them to account
on the enhanced um
measures that they will be taking
doubling uh the number of police and
increasing the
ability of the tech to help
that is the short-term fix the much
longer-term fix is through the
nationality and borders bill which i
think is that a yes
in the meantime is that a yes or no 54
million quid and we've got a record
number of people crossing the channel
yesterday um is that a yes or no for
value for money that we've given the
money to the french i think we have we
have to continue to look at um you're
not saying no are you you're not saying
yes
what i'm saying is we have to hold them
to account we've gone uh uh
to our colleagues to say you know how we
doubling the number of police officers
how we enhancing the technology how are
we dealing with this in the short term
but in the longer term it is uh through
our legislative uh system that we can
introduce as we have done just like
social care this prime minister did not
shirk the responsibility in order to
home secretary uh to deliver the
nationality and borders bill that will
ultimately in the long term deal with
this and